one of the things I've one of the tricks
I've learned though is to keep writing
no matter what and and just to just to
force yourself to write and write and
write and you know there might be times
where I've no idea what I'm going to
write but I'll just I'll just like
invent a couple of characters maybe two
or three characters and I'll just make
them talk for I don't know so it could
be 10 pages of just dialogue and you
know most of it might be pretty crappy
but somewhere in there there'll be some
sort of nuggets some little some little
things that that will be the seeds of a
bigger idea writing for me is
it's always a it's a very lonely
part of the process and I don't usually
write with other people and I usually do
Veer between crushing self-doubt and
overwhelming an overwhelming sense of
Triumph when I you know the hardest part
for me is actually the first obviously I
think probably for the most uh for most
writers is the first page the first the
first just getting into it